Most of the work that you do as a quote,
unquote ally is not with the marginalized group.
It is within your own group.
Step one of the work as a guy is you.
You gotta get some tougher skin.
You got to be able to hear that
and not run away in defensiveness
or think that it emasculates you to a place that you just can't hear
the truth of a situation.
There's ugly truth about our world and our life,
and if you want to show up and be a part of it,
you. You're gonna catch.
Especially if you're a man,
especially if you're a white man.
You're gonna catch a lot.
And if you run,
you just, like really losing what can be.
We don't even know how beautiful life can be,
what our family life can be,
what this world can be if you actually hit Equality, men,
And step one is grow some fucking skin to handle these conversations,
or else we're screwed.
I'm happy you didn't say grow some balls.